all right so back to back to temptation
so here is why fragmentation is really
bad news it gives us what is in a
technical term philosophically is known
as a double whammy so um so as we've
seen fragmentation is really a
reflection of how bad you are how good
you are at avoiding temptation but if
you are if your mind is fragmented then
there's an extra reason why you're gonna
be bad at not just avoiding temptation
but also resisting temptation the reason
for that is because remember in the
fragmented mind all these fragments are
half they have to be somehow kept
separate from your self-image
and that takes a lot of mental effort
there's again a lot of nice studies
about this but how that takes how that
takes a lot of a lot of mental work to
not just to put them separate but to
keep them separate and then you don't
you just are going to have any mental
energy left to do anything to to resist
your temptation so if your mind is
fragmented you're gonna be better at
avoiding temptation embedded resisting
temptation not great so so I want to
talk so so we've sown so this is I just
talked about it if your mind is
fragmented your ability to resist
temptation is gonna be much worse but I
want to talk about the other way around
what's happening if you do resist
temptation what's gonna happen to your
fragmented mind and I turn to an
authority about temptations Oscar Wilde
so here is a code that's very you know
famous and rightly so the only way to
get rid of a temptation is to yield to
it resist it and your soul grows sick
with longing for the things it has
forbidden to itself the desire for what
it monstrous low have made monstrous
than dollar for so what what Oscar Wilde
is saying here is that what when you're
resisting temptations that's gonna
actually contribute to what is a pretty
good description of for granted mind the
soul growing sick with longing for the
things it has forbidden to itself so
it's not just the case that your if your
mind is fragmented they're going to be
bad at resisting temptations but you're
going to resist temptations and then
you're gonna mind is gonna be even more
fragmented so you see that it's gonna
lead to this vicious circularity
so so yeah so what to do that what so
it's so you have your there you have you
know you're the bartender is asking you
for whether you want a fifth find
resisting is clearly bad because that's
gonna lead to further fragmentation what
you do you should just yield I mean that
was Oscar Wilde's advice right
you should just seal to your temptations
so I think that's also a terrible advice
I mean especially in the case of
addictions or when you're kind of on
borderline addiction case because we
know that in behavioral in in on
behavioral addictions so chemical
addictions like substance abuse
addictions the more you yield the
stronger your cravings are gonna be so
you're more difficult is gonna be next
time but even in behavioral addictions
and even in things that are not even
addictions there's some really nice
results about how the the more you lie
the more it's going to be likely that
you're gonna lie again which shouldn't
be really surprising
you